in 1978 a then-unknown nick castle first
gave shape to michael myers and john
carpenter's iconic horror flick
halloween the castle didn't reprise his
role in any of the Halloween sequels or
reboots for 1981 to 2009 the horror
world was rocked when he donned the mask
and coveralls once again for the 2018
sequel also titled Halloween here's how
Castle became Halloween's Michael Myers
aka the shape Castle explained during an
October 2018 appearance on the podcast
the subplot that he sort of stumbled
into playing Michael Myers he was
friends with John Carpenter for some
time before the young director set out
to bring Halloween to the big screen
even appearing in an uncredited cameo
and carpenters debut film Dark Star when
Carpenter went into production on
Halloween
Castle asked his buddy if he could hang
around set and watch him work hoping the
experience would demystify what
directing is really like
since Castle had aspirations to direct
himself rather than just have his pal
hang about though carpenter asked him to
stand in for the Myers role yeah well
why don't you be the guy then and just
put on the mask you hear all around in
as for how carpenter got his non acting
buddy into the menacing mind of Michael
Myers Castle noted that there wasn't
much direction other than walk there or
tilt your head I basically asked the
actor question what is my motivation and
he said your motivation is to walk from
this point to the end point that tilt
your head moment has since become a fan
favorite part of carpenters original so
much so that Halloween reboot director
David Gordon Green called back to it in
the 2018 movie carpenter himself has
since clarified his approach to casting
Castle in the role in helping him become
Michael Myers noting his pals peculiar
stride is a key element in bringing the
baddie to life
he told Entertainment Weekly on October
2018 we were buddies in film school and
I knew him man he just has a grace to
him and his dad was a choreographer I
don't know if he learned anything from
his father but he moved in a way that
nobody else moves like castle chimed in
saying what I really did was listen to
what John told me to do he was really
very much puppeteering it was John
telling me go fast go slow
tilt her head and puppeteering me
through the thing in 2017 a video
surfaced on Twitter that reportedly
showed Castle wearing a Michael Myers
mask while walking on a treadmill
little question that castles gates is a
big part of what makes Michael Myers so
it makes sense that most of the actors
pre-production prep work involved
ambling across a treadmill walking in a
brooding yet purposeful fashion is sort
of Myers's thing outside of offering
unsuspecting teens and trying to get
that butcher's knife into lorry strokes
back of course even so savvy Halloween
heads are often quick to point out the
difference in that walk throughout the
Halloween sequels with some even
noticing the difference in Greene's
latest chapter as we've come to find out
actor James Jude Courtney did the vast
majority of the walking and stalking in
the 2018 movie with the head tilt scene
in Green's Halloween marking the only
moment in the film where Castle is
actually playing the part in September
2019 Castle posted another clip of
himself creepily walking on his home
treadmill with his Michael Myers mask
covering his face the video is meant to
tease that he's preparing to become the
shape again for 2020s Halloween kills
and 2021 s Halloween ends both Castle
and Courtney are scheduled to appear as
Michael Myers in those films and the
second two the two sequels is said to
put an official end to the Michael Myers
Laurie Strode storyline Jamie Lee Curtis
is seemingly retiring the role that made
her scream Queen happy Halloween Michael
for castles parts it appears he's taken
to heart what may be his final turns
behind the eerie mask if the hilarious
Twitter post is any indication the actor
is doing his best to get into shape and
may be doing a bit more walking this
go-around Castle will return to action
when Halloween kills makes its premiere
on October 16th 2020 check out one of
our newest videos right here plus even
more looper videos about your favorite
horror movies are coming soon subscribe
to our YouTube channel and hit the bell
so you don't miss a single one
you
[Music]